[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend auch in der Politik ist
Verpackung alles Bürgergeld das klingt
nach etwas selbstverständlichem das
Bürgern zusteht und nicht wie bei Hartz
IV nach Almosen und nichts tun das
Bürgergeld also soll Hartz IV ablösen so
hat es die ampelregierung heute
beschlossen
502 Euro monatlich weniger Bürokratie
und weniger Gängelung der Empfänger
trotzdem hagelt es Kritik von allen
Seiten zu niedrig sei der Satz oder zu
hoch eine Demütigung oder im Gegenteil
eine Hängematte für Langzeitarbeitslose
Britta Buchholz berichtet aus Berlin
wenn im Jobcenter Berlin Lichtenberg
jemand eine neue Arbeit findet folgt ein
besonderes Ritual einmal den Gong
schlagen
heute dürfen das zwei einstige
Langzeitarbeitslose Zuspruch vom hohen
Besuch das Gefühl gebraucht zu werden
und ich wünsche Ihnen dass Sie das so
erleben weil sie werden echt gebraucht
in dem Job ohne sie läuft das nicht das
müsste sich immer wieder selbst sagen
und ich wünsche ihnen dass das richtig
gut klappt jetzt richtig gut klappen
soll auch das Bürgergeld es ist ein
Umdenken dass die Bundesregierung da
voranbringen will statt Gängelung heißt
das neue Credo Vertrauen statt Hartz IV
Bürgergeld
gehen wir einer der größten
Sozialreformen seit 20 Jahren an mir war
wichtig dass wir nachdem wir den
Mindestlohn in der Koalition beschlossen
haben wir jetzt zum ersten Oktober in
Kraft tritt diese große Reform gerade in
diesen Zeiten angehen die größte
Sozialreform der letzten 20 Jahre das
war aber diese Schröder setzte Hartz IV
durch was folgte Proteste
Vertrauensverlust der SPD in der Krise
nun soll Hartz IV Geschichte sein
Kernpunkte des Bürgergeldes Karenzzeiten
für Wohnen und Vermögen die ersten zwei
Jahre des Leistungsbezugs werden nicht
berücksichtigt außerdem Verbesserungen
bei der vermögensfreistellung und die
ersten sechs Monate gelten als
vertrauenszeit dann soll nur in
Ausnahmen sanktioniert werden dies ist
umstritten
die bisherigen Sanktionen haben auch
breite aufgesetzt das wird jetzt in den
ersten sechs Monaten deutlich reduziert
wir wissen aber gerade am Anfang ist es
ja wichtig schnell wieder die Hürde aus
der Arbeitslosigkeit in die
Beschäftigung zu überwinden und deswegen
ist auch am Anfang eigentlich Sanktionen
eher wichtiger die Sorge manch ein
Jobcenter wird neue bürgergeldbezieher
kaum zu Gesicht bekommen
Mitwirkungspflicht heißt das wie nehmen
Langzeitarbeitslose Termine war werden
Bewerbungen geschrieben Arbeit
angenommen Kritik von der Union
das ist der eigentliche Fehler in diesem
System es sind kaum mehr
Mitwirkungspflichten der Betroffenen und
damit auch kaum mehr eine Bereitschaft
Arbeit aufzunehmen wenn man keine
zusätzlichen finanzielle Anreizen setzen
kann der neue Regelsatz soll nach
heißplänen auf 500 und zwei Euro für
Erwachsene steigen also um rund 50 Euro
monatlich viele Sozialverbände loben
zwar das Bürgergeld aber nicht die Höhe
ich finde aber dringend dass wir über
die bürgergeldsätze reden müssen von 502
Euro ist eine Existenzsicherung bei den
Preisen im Moment überhaupt nicht
möglich auch innerhalb der Koalition gab
es Streit über die Höhe der Regelsätze
nun grünes Licht vom Kabinett für den
Entwurf auch die FDP steht dahinter das
Bürgergeld ist unbürokratischer und vor
allem ist es aufstiegsorientierter es
wird zum Beispiel endlich möglich eine
ganze Berufsausbildung nachzuholen das
sind Zeiten des Fachkräftemangels
zentral wenn ein Gesetzentwurf
angenommen wurde folgt auch hier ein
Ritual der Bundestag debattiert den
Entwurf der Bundesrat muss dann
zustimmen wenn es nach Heil geht wird
das Gesetz noch in diesem Jahr
verabschiedet
eigentlich sind dies Zeiten in denen die
Opposition links von den ampelparteien
richtig abräumen müsste SPD und Grüne
eingezwängt in ein Bündnis mit der FDP
hohe Energiepreise steigendes
Protestpotenzial doch die Linkspartei
kann davon kaum profitieren weil sie
sich seit Monaten selbst zerlegt die
Rede von Sarah Wagenknecht im Bundestag
in der sie nicht Putin sondern der
Ampelkoalition die Schuld am
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Russland gab ist
ein neuer Tiefpunkt prominente Politiker
verlassen die Linke die Partei so
scheint es schafft sich selbst ab Andrea
Maurer berichtet
es ist diese Rede im Bundestag
ein Energielieferanten vom Zaun zu
brechen es ist diese Rede die zu viel
ist für Ulrich Schneider Deutschlands
bekanntesten sozial-lobbyisten seit 2016
Mitglied der LINKEN er tritt aus ich
kann und ich will nicht in einer Partei
sein deren Bundestagsfraktion eine Sarah
Wagenknecht mit ihrer doch die Familie
und zum Teil diskreditierenden Diktion
und ihren ja schon im Vorfeld bekannten
Aussagen
zu diesem
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
und all dem was damit zusammenhängt so
in Schaufenster stellt es reicht sagen
auch drei ostdeutsche linken Politikerin
über 2.500 Unterschriften haben sie
inzwischen gesammelt darunter die
Bundestagsabgeordnete Martina Renner sie
fordern den Ausschluss von Wagenknecht
aus der Fraktion den Rücktritt der
Fraktionschefs die Wagenknecht haben
sprechen lassen
ich werde diese Aufforderung nicht
nachkommen
warum weil es dafür keine Begründung
gibt und weil die von einzelnen gemacht
worden ich habe so viel jetzt
Unterstützung erfahren ich glaube auch
dass das überhaupt kein Problem lösen
würde das Problem die Fraktion ist
gespalten Partei und Fraktionsspitze
sind gespalten Parteichef schürdewahn
geht heute in einem Zeitungsinterview
auf Distanz zu Wagenknecht und zur
Fraktionsführung die Missachtung
demokratischer Beschlüsse bei Auftritten
im Namen der Fraktion durch einzelne
Abgeordnete schadet unserer Partei
massiv es ist Aufgabe der
Fraktionsführung dafür zu sorgen dass
sich so etwas nicht wiederholt
Leipzig vor anderthalb Wochen linke
Auftakt zum sogenannten heißen Herbst
Wagenknecht soll sprechen wird
ausgeladen auf Druck der Parteispitze
wie sie sagt Problem nur vertagt drei
Tage später spricht sie für die Fraktion
im Bundestag Wagenknecht ist mehr als
eine abweichlerin sie hat eine
Machtbasis in der Fraktion mindestens
acht Abgeordnete die ihre Meinung teilen
eine Pro wagenknecht-petition hat
bereits über 6.000 Unterschriften
Wagenknecht greift nun den Parteichef an
nennt ihn eine Zitat Fehlbesetzung das
Zitat bezieht sich ja darauf dass er
gesagt hat ich soll irgendwie
ausgeschlossen werden aus der Fraktion
oder dass er alles deplatziert und da
habe ich eben gesagt also jemand der in
der jetzigen Situation so agiert der hat
offenbar gar kein Gespür für die
Probleme im Land für die Stimmung in der
Bevölkerung für die Sorgen der Menschen
und das ist natürlich jetzt nicht
unbedingt gut mit den Qualitäten
Vorsitzender einer linken Partei zu sein
es ist ein Strudel nach unten mit dem
ehemaligen Bundestagsabgeordneten Fabio
demasi ist gestern eine weitere
prominente Figur aus der linken
ausgetreten Grund das eklatante Versagen
der maßgeblichen Akteure in dieser
Partei gerade jetzt wo die soziale Frage
größer wird wo die Linke die soziale
Opposition sein könnte die sie sein will
ist die gespaltene Partei ihrer realen
Bedeutung ein Stück näher gerückt
und uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt Janine
Wissler eine der beiden Vorsitzenden der
Linkspartei guten Abend Frau Wissler sie
haben es gerade gehört Frau Wagenknecht
findet dass die Parteiführung der
Linkspartei nicht über ausreichende
Qualitäten verfügt und fordert indirekt
den Rücktritt ihres co-vorsitzenden
Martin schierdewan was ist ihre Reaktion
darauf
wir haben vor zweieinhalb Monaten einen
Bundesparteitag gehabt da ist eine neue
Parteispitze gewählt worden mit
überzeugenden Mehrheiten und alle sind
gehalten sich jetzt an diese
demokratischen Beschlüsse sowohl
inhaltlicher Art als auch personeller
Art sich den verbunden zu fühlen und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen sie haben sie in
ihrem Beitrag auch angemerkt wir haben
eine so tiefe soziale Krise die
vergaspreise verdreifachen sich die
Menschen wissen nicht wie Sie Ihre
Einkäufe und ihre Rechnung bezahlen
sollen in einer solchen Situation hat
die linkener Aufgabe und zwar die Kraft
der sozialen Gerechtigkeit zu sein und
dafür zu kämpfen dass Menschen nicht in
die Armut abrutschen und dafür sind wir
alle gefordert Partei und
Bundestagsfraktion und dafür werden wir
gebraucht Sarah Wagenknecht hat ja in
ihrer bundestagsrede die gleiche
Wortwahl benutzt wie Vladimir Putin als
sie vom beispiellosen Wirtschaftskrieg
gegen Russland sprach was haben Sie
eigentlich gedacht als sie diese Rede
gehört haben
ich halte das für ein falsches Vokabular
also es geht mir gar nicht um den
Begriff das Wirtschaftskrieges den
benutzen auch andere aber natürlich ist
es eben nicht so dass die deutsche
Bundesregierung den Krieg vom oder den
Wirtschaftskrieg vom Zaun gebrochen hat
sondern russland hat die Ukraine
überfallen und ich finde das muss man
schon immer wieder deutlich machen
ansonsten finde ich sollten wir das
Hauptaugenmerk jetzt darauf legen wie
wir die sozialen Verwerfungen abfedern
können durch eine übergewinnsteuer ein
gaspreisdeckel durch direkte Hilfen und
eben auch ein Anschluss als 9 € Ticket
ich finde das sind die zentralen Fragen
die Linke heute stark machen müssen und
für eine konsequente Anti Kriegspartei
muss gelten wir verurteilen natürlich
jeden Krieg und wir verurteilen in
konsequent und das ist meine Position
dazu aber auch ihre eigene Partei
diskutiert ja über die Führungsfrage sie
haben der Fraktionsspitze vorgeworfen
sie hätte Wagenknecht im Bundestag nicht
reden lassen dürfen aber hätten sie als
Parteichefin nicht eingreifen müssen und
das verhindern
also grundsätzlich bin ich der Meinung
dass Abgeordnete unserer Partei im
Bundestag und in den Landtagen die
Positionen der parteifreten müssen
nämlich die Positionen die wir bei
demokratischen zusammengesetzten
Parteitagen beschließen und ich hätte
mir gewünscht dass eben in dieser Rede
sehr deutlich gemacht worden wäre was
sind unsere sozialpolitischen
Forderungen was sind die Punkte die wir
auch gemeinsam in einer Fraktionsklausur
und ein Parteivorstand beschlossen haben
das hätte im Vordergrund stehen müssen
und dass es unsere Position dazu und
deswegen will ich noch mal dazu
auffordern dass wir alle jetzt gemeinsam
ja DIE LINKE Oppositionsrolle wahrnehmen
und dass wir uns nicht mit uns selber
beschäftigen sondern dass wir uns damit
beschäftigen wie wir die soziale Not
lindern können und da sind alle
gefordert und dazu brauchen wir eine
linke die vor allem eben ja die sozialen
Verhältnisse kritisiert und nicht
miteinander streitet aber Sie können es
ja beeinflussen sie sind ja die
ko-parteichefin der Linkspartei zögern
Sie vielleicht auch mit Sahra
Wagenknecht rauszuwerfen weil sie wissen
dass Frau Wagenknecht die Mehrheit der
Linkspartei hinter sich hat
also ich werde nicht über
Ausschlussverfahren und sonstiges jetzt
an der Stelle diskutieren ich will aber
deutlich machen dass der Bundesparteitag
und das ist das größte das höchste
Beschlussgremium dieser Partei dass der
Bundesparteitag klare Entscheidung
getroffen hat und er hat ein Antrag
beschlossen zum Thema soziale
ökologischen Umbau und auch zum Thema
Ukraine Krieg und diese Position sind
mit breiten Mehrheiten beschlossen
worden und die gelten auch und ich sehe
nicht dass die Linke jetzt zerrissen
wäre ganz im Gegenteil ich merke dass
gerade die Genossinnen und Genossen an
der Basis jetzt gerade Proteste aufbauen
dass sie mobilisieren dass sie in
Bündnissen arbeiten und dass sie
versuchen eben Menschen auf die Straße
zu bringen um jetzt den Druck zu
entfachen den es eben braucht um eben
die ampelregierung zu sozialen
Zugeständnissen zu bewegen das ist meine
Wahrnehmung von der Partei wir haben
eine gewählte Parteiführung ihr arbeitet
gut zusammen und die arbeitet jetzt
daran die Linke wieder nach vorne zu
bringen vor allem aber daran dass die
sozialen Härten die mit dieser diese
verbunden sind 14 Millionen Menschen in
Armut in diesem Land und die Fragen
müssen wir uns kümmern und das tun wir
mit aller Kraft und da steht die
absolute Mehrheit in der Partei hinter
uns und das haben die Beschlüsse des
Bundesparteitags auch gezeigt verstehe
schon dass sie lieber über die Sache
reden wollen aber Fakt ist ja dass die
zwei Parteimitglieder zwei prominente
Parteimitglieder ausgetreten sind Wagen
sie eine Prognose wie lange es die
Linkspartei noch gibt
ich bedauere diese Austritte sehr also
sowohl Ulrich Schneider dass er die
Partei verlassen hat das bedauere ich
und natürlich auch Fabio De Masi mir tut
das weh und mir tut das Leid die beiden
aber auch andere die in den letzten
Wochen die Entscheidung getroffen haben
ihre Mitgliedschaft zu beenden und ich
bin der Meinung dass wir eine Opposition
links von der Ampel brauchen und dass
die Linke auch da eine starke Basis hat
in den kommunalen Parlamenten in den
Landesparlamenten her vor Ort in den
Städten und Gemeinden und daran sollte
man gemeinsam arbeiten weil es ist ja es
ist doch dringend notwendig dass eben
gerade jetzt in dieser sozialen Krise
die sozialpolitischen Forderungen stark
gemacht werden und die vertreten wir und
wir dürfen doch die Opposition gegen die
Ampel nicht den Parteien von rechts
überlassen dazu brauchen wir die Linke
und ja dazu haben wir sehr sehr viele
Mitglieder die genau dafür tagtäglich
kämpfen die sich engagieren in
mieterbündnissen bei der Hartz IV
Erwartungen die bei der Tafel
mitarbeiten oder sozialbündnisse
aufbauen diese Mitglieder diese das
Herzstück dieser Partei die tragen diese
Partei und solange wir diese großartigen
tollen Mitglieder haben ist mir nicht
bange um die Zukunft der Partei sagt die
Vorsitzende der Linkspartei Janine
Wissler danke für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet und bei uns geht
es jetzt weiter mit den Nachrichten und
die beginnen mit der Ukraine Hanna
zahlreiche Ortschaften und Städte hat
die Ukraine ja mittlerweile im Osten des
Landes zurückerobert und meldet nun neue
Hinweise auf russische Kriegsverbrechen
insgesamt 40 Verdachtsfälle gäbe es
allein in der Region Harke verklärte das
Innenministerium der ukrainische
Präsident selenski besuchte heute die
befreite Stadt istjung und sprach von
einem schockierenden Anblick
vergleichbar mit den Bildern aus Butcher
nach dem Abzug der russischen Truppen
in Schweden hat Ministerpräsidentin
Magdalena anders schon drei Tage nach
der Parlamentswahl ihren Rücktritt
angekündigt Grund ist der knappe
Wahlsieg des Oppositionellen
rechtsbündnisses nach Auszählung von
mehr als 99 Prozent der Stimmen kam das
von anders schon angeführte Linksbündnis
auf 173 Sitze im Parlament das
konservative rechte Lager holte 176 das
lag auch am Erfolg der
rechtspopulistischen Schwedendemokraten
die zum ersten Mal zweitstärkste Kraft
wurden
die Bundesregierung hat heute mehrere
Gesetzesvorhaben auf den Weg gebracht
darunter unter anderem einen
pflegeentlastungsgesetz das Kliniken
dazu verpflichten soll mit einer
ausreichenden Zahl an Pflegekräften zu
arbeiten ab kommendem Jahr in einer
Erprobungsphase ab 2025 dann verbindlich
außerdem will die Regierung mit
Steuerentlastungen die Auswirkungen der
hohen Inflation auf die Einkommenssteuer
abmildern Stichwort kalte Progression
zudem sollen ab Oktober für eineinhalb
Jahre die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas gesenkt
und ab Januar das Kindergeld erhöht
werden
das Bundesinnenministerium hat die
rockerähnliche Gruppierung United
Tribuns verboten ihre Mitglieder sollen
unter anderem für Sexualstraftaten
Menschenhandel und versuchte
Tötungsdelikte verantwortlich sein am
Morgen durchsuchte die Polizei mehr als
100 Objekte in neuen Bundesländern dabei
wurden zahlreiche Waffen sichergestellt
die 2004 gegründete Gruppe hat laut
Innenministerium etwa 100 Mitglieder in
Deutschland
angesichts der steigenden Kosten für
Strom und Gas haben die
energieministerinnen und Minister der
Länder den Bund aufgefordert einen
preisdeckel einzuführen zudem sprachen
sich die Ministerinnen und Minister bei
ihrem Treffen in Hannover für mehr
Solarenergie auf Dächern aus so soll
laut dem gemeinsamen Beschluss zum
Beispiel eine photovoltaikpflicht für
alle Neubauten diskutiert werden
worum es in der Rede zur Lage der EU
geht ist sofort klar
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen erscheint vom Europaparlament in
Straßburg in Ukrainisch Blau-Gelb und in
Begleitung von Oleander der Ehefrau des
ukrainischen Präsidenten die EU ist im
krisenmodus erst recht seit putinen die
Ukraine überfiel von der Lions Hauptjob
ist es den Laden zusammenzuhalten bei
den bislang sieben sanktionspaketen
gegen Russland ist das mit einigen
Schwierigkeiten gelungen jetzt will die
eu-kommissionschefin die Energiepreise
drücken und schob der Rede direkt einen
Gesetzesvorschlag dazu hinterher Isabel
Schäfers war ein Straßburg dabei Ursula
von der Leyen hat alles perfekt in Szene
gesetzt ihr Outfit ihren Gast doch
bereits nach wenigen Minuten hakt es im
Ablauf für die kommissionspräsidentin
ist beim Gespräch zwischen der
Parlamentspräsidentin und der
ukrainischen First Lady kein Platz
vorgesehen aber Ursula von der Leyen
bleibt schließlich ist es Ihr Tag in
ihrer Rede betont sie was die EU bereits
für die Ukraine geleistet habe und
verspricht weitere Unterstützung
die europäische Solidarität mit der
Ukraine wird unerschütterlich bleiben ab
Tag 1 stand Europa an der Seite der
Ukraine mit Waffen mit finanzieller
Unterstützung mit Gastfreundschaft
gegenüber Flüchtlingen und mit den
härtesten Sanktionen die die Welt je
gesehen hat aber schnell wird klar die
EU ist auch mit ihrer eigenen Krise
beschäftigt die kommissionspräsidentin
nutzt ihre Rede um deutlich zu machen
dass Europa etwas tun will gegen die
hohen Strompreise in diesen Zeiten ist
es falsch außergewöhnlich hohe Gewinne
zu machen und vom Krieg zu profitieren
auf dem Rücken unserer Verbraucher
gemein sind die hohen Gewinne die
entstehen weil der Strompreis in Europa
vor allem vom teuren Gas bestimmt wird
die Produktion von Strom etwa aus
erneuerbaren Energiequellen oder aus
Atomkraft ist wesentlich günstiger der
Verkaufspreis richtet sich aber nach dem
teuren Strom so entstehen derzeit bei
einigen Stromproduzenten ungewöhnlich
hohe Gewinne sogenannte zufallsgewinne
diese sollen nun teilweise abgeschöpft
werden um damit Haushalte und Firmen zu
entlasten die Stromproduzenten sollen
künftig maximal 180 Euro pro
Megawattstunde bekommen so der Plan der
Kommission das kann jetzt sehr schnell
gehen ich hoffe das Ende September der
Rat entscheidet und dann kann das sofort
umgesetzt werden technisch am Gasmarkt
und Elektrizitätsmarkt und die
Mitgliedstaaten haben sofort die Mittel
umgezielt die wollen aber den Haushalte
zu unterstützen es gehe dabei um rund
140 Milliarden Euro der Tenor im
Parlament im Prinzip richtig aber auf
die konkrete Umsetzung komme es an wir
sind vor allen Dingen an der Lage wo die
Märkte nicht mehr funktionieren ich
glaube da kann man zu drastischen
befristeten Maßnahmen greifen um
Gaspreis und Strompreis zu trennen ich
halte es für richtig
einige Staaten werden kaum Geld
abschöpfen können andere sehr viel die
Verteilung dieser Gelder zwischen den
Ländern aber auch innerhalb der Länder
liegt jetzt bei den Mitgliedstaaten eine
echte europäische Solidarität um über
den Winter zu kommen gibt es nicht das
ist der schwächste Punkt
das alles mag Olena silenska und ihrem
Land erstmal nicht helfen aber Ursula
von der Leyen reist in der Nacht noch
nach Kiew und trifft dann auch Präsident
selenski doch ihre Rede hat gezeigt die
größten Herausforderungen warten für die
kommissionspräsidentin wohl in Brüssel
und wir machen weiter mit den
Nachrichten von Hannah und da bleiben
wir beim Thema Energieversorgung ja ganz
genau denn wieder macht der Gasversorger
uneper Schlagzeilen ein
milliardenschweres Rettungspaket hatte
der Staat ja bereits im Juli geschnürt
doch nun kommt die Meldung dass auch
eine Mehrheitsbeteiligung des Bundes an
juni-park geprüft wird Valerie Haller in
Frankfurt warum wird dieser Schritt
jetzt in Erwägung gezogen und was würde
es bedeuten wenn es so kommt es wird in
Erwägung gezogen weil es dem Unternehmen
offenbar schlechter geht als angenommen
der Staat muss wohl noch mal nachlegen
Juniper ist Großhändler versorgt
Industriekunden Stadtwerke und
Wohnungseigentümer also eine Unmenge von
Kunden einen Zusammenbruch des größten
gashändlers des Landes kann sich der
Bund schlicht nicht leisten Juniper
rutscht immer tiefer in die Krise seit
Russland überhaupt kein Gas mehr liefert
häufen sich die täglichen Verluste des
Unternehmen macht bis zu 100 Millionen
Euro Miese am Tag die geplanten hil
reichen nicht mehr dabei ist die Summe
die bisher schon geplant war schon
gigantisch 30 Prozent Staatsbeteiligung
und Kredite ergeben ein Hilfspaket von
insgesamt 20 Milliarden Euro doch
Juniper braucht mehr in einer
Pflichtmitteilung heißt es heute
aufgrund der gestiegenen Unsicherheiten
prüfen die Beteiligten unter anderem
eine direkte Kapitalerhöhung die zu
einer signifikanten Mehrheitsbeteiligung
des Bundes an Juniper führen würde
Milliardenverluste und eine mögliche
Verstaatlichung stürzen Juniper an der
Börse Knie tief ins Minus die Aktie
fällt heute um 18 Prozent nicht nur
uniper hat Liquiditätsprobleme auch
mehrere Stadtwerke sind kurz davor
Staatshilfe zu beantragen die Lage am
Energiemarkt desto angespannt wie noch
nie danke Valerie für diese Einschätzung
ja und auch bei der Lufthansa ist der
Staat mit Milliarden als Retter
eingesprungen während der
corona-pandemie als der Konzern in
Straucheln geriet jetzt gut zwei Jahre
später hat der Bund seine letzten
Anteile an der Airline verkauft und
unter dem Strich einen deutlichen Gewinn
gemacht und zwar von 760 Millionen Euro
die Lufthansa ist jetzt wieder komplett
in privater Hand und jetzt noch der
Blick auf die Lottozahlen die lauten
2 9 11 16 39 48 Superzahl 5 alle Angaben
wie immer ohne Gewähr
in Köln ist am Abend in einer großen
Gala der Deutsche Fernsehpreis verliehen
worden auch das ZDF war erfolgreich und
konnte gleich acht der begehrten
Glastrophäen gewinnen ein Preis ging an
Giovanni Zarella in der Kategorie beste
Einzelleistung als
unterhaltungsmoderator auch der beste
Fernsehfilm ist eine ZDF Co-Produktion
und zwar die Wannseekonferenz und ein
Fernsehpreis erhielt unsere Kollegin
Katrin Eigendorf die auch immer wieder
hier im heute-journal zu sehen ist
aktuell mit ihren Berichten aus der
Ukraine sie gewann in der Kategorie
beste persönliche Leistung information
[Applaus]
Schlange stehen das können wohl höflich
stilvoll und ohne Rempelei nur die
Briten die BBC hat auf ihrer Homepage
eine extra Anleitung dazu veröffentlicht
was man braucht um die Schlange bis zum
Sarg der Queen durchzuhalten Regel
Nummer eins richtig anziehen und
Handyladegerät dabei haben es kann 30
Stunden dauern bis man Westminster Hall
erreicht Blumen Campingstühle und
Schlafsäcke dürfen nicht mit
hineingenommen werden genauso wenig wie
politische Botschaften oder Werbung
Yasin herlein hat sich eingereiht
sie machen das Gut geduldig und
diszipliniert die Briten das Schlange
stehen ist womöglich genauso wie Fußball
Rugby oder Cricket auf der Insel
erfunden worden die Schlange um den
aufgebahrten sagt Königin Elisabeth II
sehen zu dürfen ist Meilen lang reicht
bis ans andere Ufer der Themse
wer ist in die Westminster Hall schafft
hat dann einen kurzen Moment um sich
jeder auf seine Weise von der Monarchin
zu verabschieden
vorangegangen war am Nachmittag ein
Trauerzug der sich Punkt 14 Uhr 22
Ortszeit in Bewegung setzte
zunächst war es ein Strom rot
uniformierter Soldaten die langsamen
Schrittes den Buckingham Palast
verließen
dann der sagt der Königin gehüllt in die
königliche Standarte zuoberst die
staatskrone
in der ersten Reihe der hinter ihre vier
Kinder König Charles Prinzessin an und
Prinz Edward in Uniform Prinz Andrew im
trauerfrag in der zweiten Reihe die
männlichen Enkel William Harry und Peter
Philipps von ihnen trug nur Prinz
William Uniform
die Ironie dass die zuletzt doch stark
in Ungnade gefallenen Prinzen Andrew und
Harry die einzigen Royals sind die in
einem Krieg im Einsatz waren nun aber
Zivil tragen mussten durchaus
bemerkenswert
zehntausende sollten den Weg viele
applaudierten in dem Moment als der sagt
sie passierte
doch es sollte nicht vergessen werden
dass bei weitem nicht jeder in der
britischen Hauptstadt in diesen Tagen
vom royalen Fieber erfasst ist
das alles ist ziemlich altmodisch zu
groß und es wird viel zu viel Geld
ausgegeben für Leute die nur aufgrund
ihrer Geburt das sind was sie sind das
bedeutet dass jemand der in eine
bestimmte Familie oder an einem
bestimmten Ort geboren ist besser ist
als andere das sollte man unsere Kinder
nicht lehren
die Westminster Hall das Ziel des
trauerzugs ist Teil des Westminster
Palasts des Sitzes der beiden Häuser des
britischen Parlaments
dass die Königin hier aufgebahrt ist
unterstreicht einmal mehr wie engen
Großbritannien demokratische und
monarchische Tradition verwoben sind
4 volle Tage mit der Sarg hier nun
verbleiben bis zur feierlichen
Beisetzung am kommenden Montag
[Musik]
und das war es von uns hier geht es
weiter mit dem Sportstudio und den
Highlights der Champions League und
unser heute journal Update gibt es heute
gegen halb eins mit Christopher Wehrmann
morgen steht an diesem Platz Christian
Sievers mit Hanna Zimmermann einen
schönen Abend ihnen tschüss
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter heute
abend wir haben es aktuell mit einem
Vierer druckfeld zu tun ein hoch und ein
Tief im Norden stehen einem tief und
einem Hoch im Süden gegenüber und diese
Konstellation verstärkt noch einmal die
Luftzufuhr sowohl die kalte als auch die
warme und die Luftmassengrenze genau
über Deutschland brachte uns heute
diesen Dauerregen in der warmen feuchten
Luft im Süden aber bilden sich jetzt
seit dem Nachmittag teils schwere
Gewitter mit Hagel Starkregen und
Sturmböen morgen setzt sich dann so
langsam von Norden her aber die kühlere
Luft durch und dieser gewittrige Regen
wird immer weiter Richtung Süden
gedrängt aber heute Nacht sind noch mal
weiter Gewitter unterwegs vor allem mit
Starkregen Potenzial achten Sie hier
also auf die Warnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes das Regenband insgesamt
wandert dann schon mal langsam Richtung
Süden sonst meist trocken mit einigen
Schauern an der Küste dazu sinken die
Temperaturen auf 9 Grad in einigen
Tälern der Mittelgebirge und 17 Grad am
Oberrhein morgen haben wir im Norden und
in der Mitte dann ähnliche Temperaturen
wie heute mit 15 bis 20 Grad im Süden
ist es mit maximal 22 Grad aber deutlich
kühler denn hier ist eben dieser
gewittrige Regen auch noch unterwegs
Starkregen ist weiterhin möglich ein
Tagesverlauf zieht sich das Ganze dann
weiter in den Süden zurück sonst
wechseln sich Sonne und Wolken ab morgen
einige Schauer haben wir nachmittags
aber an der Nordsee und dazu diesen
kräftigen westlichen Wind der uns am
Wochenende dann richtig kühle
Temperaturen teils nur noch 8 Grad am
Alpenrand bringt dazu ist es regnerisch
und windig es ist also ein richtiges
Herbstwochenende tschüss